I want to talk about an interesting issue
with everybody today.
Should Democrats
have Republicans in their administration.
Today I'm going to tell you about what two
democratic candidates said about this tool.
See Gabbert and Joe Biden and then I'm going
to talk about the concept of Republicans and
democratic administrations, whether there's
virtue in in some abstract sense in bipartisanship.
And lastly, I'll tell you why.
This is actually a pretty meaningless promise
to even be making, so let's get right into
it.
You all know I am not a supporter of tool.
See Gabard, she is a soon to be former Congresswoman
from Hawaii who has missed the majority of
her house votes recently.
Uh, I am a, uh, supporting other people in
the democratic primary, not her, but she was
asked would you have Republicans and independence
in your hypothetical administration?
And she initially said, not only is she open
to it, she would commit to it.
Let's check it out.
You talked so much about reaching across the
aisle.
Yes, you can commit to Republicans or independent
into a gabardine administration.
I would make that commitment.
The first and foremost a qualification for
those that I would select for a service in
my cabinet and in my administration would
be those who are committed to putting service
to the our country and the American people
first.
We should not be afraid of diversity of ideas
and, and take inspiration from the team of
rivals that Abraham Lincoln to cha, uh, chose
to surround himself with, um, and, and draw
strength from that and being able to deliver
that service and results to the American people
rising above partisan interests.
And again, putting service to the people above
everything else.
She is willing to make a commitment to having
Republicans in her administration.
Now, of course, this is always an easier commitment
to make when you have absolutely no shot at
having an administration in which you would
decide about having Republicans or Democrats.
But let's take her at her word, except she
was asked to confirm.
Oh, so you're committing to Republicans in
your administration.
She immediately backtracks and says, well,
I'm committing not to require that everybody
be a Democrat, which is a very different thing
to commit to.
Then having Republicans.
This is the second part of the clip, which
a lot of people have not seen.
So just to clarify that right now, if you're
president of the United States, there will
be, I will commit to making sure that there
is no partisan, um, requirement for those
who I choose to serve in my administration.
Instead, looking at that most important qualification,
are you someone who is committed to serving
the people of this country, uh, not serving
for your own personal profit or benefit or
anything else and that you've got the experience
to be able to, um, to be able to do the job?
Okay, so before we even go further, notice
that she Insta flips.
She first says, I, yes, Republicans, I would
commit to that.
And then she's asked, so are you, you're committing
to Republicans and your administration?
And she says, well, I'm committing not to
require everybody be a Democrat.
Okay, cool tool.
So a good one.
Now before we go further, remember that Joe
Biden said he would be open to a Republican
running mate, but he can't think of one specifically
that he'd be interested in right now.
And he was crushed by some Democrats.
Remember this clip?
Why wonder if Joe Biden would consider
choosing a Republican as a running mate?
The answer is I would, but I can't think of
one now.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Look, no, I'm serious.
No.
Here's what I mean.
Let me find out.
Know other, some really decent Republicans
that are out there still.
Now let's think about this more theoretically
and then specifically, this is basically the
right answer in principle, right?
I'm open to anyone who is the right person
regardless of party.
If you're asking me, are there any Republicans
today in 2020 that I can think of as running
mates?
I can't think of one that's actually the right
answer, but let's take it a step further.
There's nothing inherently good about bipartisan
bipartisanship.
We wouldn't say, imagine that one party is
made up of all white supremacists.
We wouldn't say, well, I want people from
all parties in my administration, including
the white supremacist party.
Nobody would expect that.
Now, I'm not saying the Republican party is
all made up of white supremacists, but the
point I'm trying to make is there's not any
inherent virtue in saying we will have people
from all parties or from all political perspectives
in my administration, there are bad parties,
there are bad political perspectives.
So the first thing I think is important to
understand is that on the left we have to
be consistent.
Okay?
If we like the idea of tool seeping open to
Republicans and the administration, it should
be the same for Joe Biden.
Joe is being upfront.
He says, I'm open to it, but I can't think
of anybody.
I get it.
There's a difference between a Republican
vice president and a Republican somewhere
else in an administration.
But if we liked the idea of democratic candidates
being open to Republicans and administrations,
then we've got to be okay with it no matter
who says it.
But I don't actually care about that.
So specifically the idea of should Democrats
have Republicans in their administration?
In theory, it's not controversial.
We should have the group of people to advance
a progressive agenda in total.
If that includes strategically selecting some
Republicans to put in some particular positions,
then why not?
We should not ideologically rule out Republicans
with a partisan test.
But the reality is that number one, for the
most part, it's not going to be Republicans
that help us achieve a progressive agenda.
So again, there's no particular virtue in
saying, sure, I'll have Republicans, but let
me kind of give you the cheat sheet real quick.
This entire question is a meaningless political
game.
I'll explain to you why Tulsi didn't say cabinet.
She said, administration, and then she said,
well, I'm not saying I would have Republicans.
I'm saying I wouldn't require, everybody has
to be a Democrat.
Joe Biden said, sure, I'd have a Republican
vice president except I can't actually think
of one.
The number of people in presidential administrations
is gigantic and it's actually no big deal
to put Republicans in some positions, including
the less overtly political ones, and I would
go even further.
Could I find a tolerable Republican to put
in my administration in a position of some
actual power to appease those who find virtue
abstractly in bipartisanship?
Sure.
If you said to me, you've got to find some
prominent Republican and put, put him or her
in your administration, I could find a role
for like Utah Senator and former Massachusetts
governor, Mitt Romney.
Based on the things he did correctly in Massachusetts,
I could find something for him to do where
he wouldn't really do any damage and I could
say, Hey, I've got Republicans in my administration.
Would he be the best person for whatever position?
Maybe, maybe not.
But if the point is to find Republicans to
say, you have Republicans in your administration,
okay, I can find something for them to do.
The point here is, and the takeaway is this
is a meaningless political game in that it
all comes down to what you mean by Republicans
in your administration.
I'm fine with what tools he said, even though
she walked it back and it doesn't even really
sound like she meant it.
I'm fine with what Joe Biden said as long
as he and I agree that in the 2020 Republican
party, I can't think of any prominent Republican
that would be better as a vice president than
someone that we can actually find choosing
from Democrats.
So let's not go nuts with the litmus tests.
Let's not go nuts with the concern trolling
the gasping that Joe Biden is open to a Republican
vice president, even though he can't actually
think of one that Tulsi Gabbert said she would
be open to Republicans or her administration.
Biden would obviously pick a Democrat for
vice president if he's the nominee.
Tool C has no shot.
It's an interesting theoretical discussion
and that's that there's no particular virtue
in bipartisanship, but if you're trying to
check boxes that you have people from all
parties, you can do it safely and without
actually putting toxic Republicans in particular
in positions where they would have any serious
amount of power or influence over the policy
of your administration.
That's all this is.